so they're actually kept to their me
that I've gotta kind of two things at
one is the blog I also have wrote wrote
this book and so the anyway firm for
many years I was I wasn't very happy
with what was going on there and I was
kind of observing it okay this is
becoming more more problematic there's
this you know not only are our people
kind of not admitting if this isn't
working out but you know there's there's
this whole you know there's a lot of
kind of public promotion of the subject
and and it's a very difficult
complicated separate refute a lot of
people don't understand it and so it's
this is really not a healthy situations
that someone should kind of you know
kind of clearly explained larger
community physicists and also to non
physicists you know exactly what the
situation is here and and so I wrote an
article about this and then I finally
wrote this book and it took a while to
get the book publishers that's a long
and interesting story but but then Wow
after I guess after after the book was
written I also started it's hard to see
there are a couple other physicists
which started blogs and thought well
this isn't interesting interesting thing
to try to do and I can both talk about
you know these issues related to string
theory and things which I was trying to
get out through the book but also kind
of follow it in a day to day basis and
also just kind of write about whatever
I'm interested in so the the blog I
guess I don't worry a lot about who
about the about the audience for it it's
kind of written because I realized it's
very much it's really just kind of
whatever whatever I would like to read
so I'm gonna write I'm kind of writing
whatever I would like to read so this so
there's somebody out there exactly like
me they much find this really
fascinating and if there's something
quite different they find it not at all
interesting and so but because of that
it's um
the kinds of things in the blog are
often you know if I if I learned
something or something new interesting
going on and even in pure mathematics
I'll be writing about that or pretty
much anything going on in between
mathematics and physics I'll be writing
about that writing a lot about the LHC
and but and also just about whatever is
going on in this controversy over a
string theory and um it's kind of
memorial at this my book came out and
there was at the same time there's a
book by another physicist with a similar
point of view to mine
that came out so that that caused a lot
of controversies with a lot of reviews
and a lot of argument going on on these
blogs and a lot of people refer to this
as the string Wars and so the there's
this very for for a year or two there
there was a kind of a very interesting
if you're interesting this kind of thing
there's an interesting warfare in terms
of blog postings and comments going on
on my site and various others and that
was a all that would lead to all sorts
and strange things
some I mean III often learn you know
interesting things from common you know
so so now that the blog is fairly well
known so you know people will write in
comment so I've logged often telling me
about something I hadn't heard about her
new button you don't know about and that
that's where interesting or though
they'll often send it to be privately by
email saying you know hey you might be
interested in this and so I get a lot of
that and learn a lot that way
well one interesting I thought amusing
let the whole string theory thing
discussion was that it's a it really is
it's an incredibly complex and a
difficult subject and so it's really
hard to overemphasize how it's a
something that really nobody understands
very well and even the people who are
the most experts at it are and it's
amazing experience of having a
conversation with some Nobel Prize
winners who people are thought of as the
the brightest people this field and
asking them what they think of string
theory and they'll say you know I don't
know I don't really understand what's
going on I don't want to comment on it
and it's just I'm baffled by it so one
interesting thing about the some of
these discussions in the blog was I
found it one way to figure out exactly
what's going on in in string theory and
whether you know something is really a
problem or or not is to just put up my
understanding of it you know in a blog
post or in a comment or whatever and
then fairly quickly you would find that
either you know either I was wrong and
there there was some reason that this
actually made sense even though I
thought it didn't and this would I would
I would quickly often abusively he
explained me what an idiot I was and why
this was you know here's here's the
answer what you really should have known
or and then then I found out that okay I
learned something or or or often I would
found out that if I was right if there
really was a problem here the answer I
would get would often be just this abuse
of oh you know you're a complete jerk
and you're moron and but but no no no
scientific answer to the scientific
question so that was one that was
actually an interesting way to kind of
see exactly what the state of research
and the subject was by kind of probing
it and trying to and and getting that
kind of response from some of the more
hostile people and
I mean it's mostly a positive thing I
mean one thing to say about the one of
the main problems with with the blog's
one most annoying thing about the blog's
is especially if a lot of people are
reading it you're really in a situation
where other there's a small number of
people who really understand this and
know what's going on and have something
really sensible to say about it there's
a very large number of people who have
some kind of interest in it and you know
have the time and energy to sit there
and write uninformed things on your blog
and and kind of just so-so I actually
did I think I'd like some vlogs I
actually delete a lot of the comments
submitted to my blog and try to keep the
noise level down and so that's the most
probably the most discouraging thing
about the whole experience it's just
this the number of people out there who
kind of want to go on about this and
argue about this but don't know what
they're talking about and want to kind
of fill the internet and all information
sources they get their hands on with
kind of under form nonsense so there's a
lot of that but the but but just the
kind of discussion of the subject and of
its problems which I think went on in
these blogs and which you're in which
you know if you're interested you can
now have information could go and see
and read I don't think there's really
any other forum you know it's an amazing
format for that there's really no other
way did you know that discussion could
could be held in that way and um and and
also in the internet just provides this
kind of amazing access to information of
a sort which is just totally unlike
anything we've had before you can you
know just google some term and
immediately have access to all sorts of
often high-level discussions of the
subject and um I think the one well it's
actually made some of the fattest nosov
particle theory actually a bit worse in
the sense that one thing that used to
kind of slow down fads was just the how
long it took to communicate them to
people the mean you know the certain
problem that people might have started
working on some idea at Princeton or
Harvard but it would take a while for
that news of that and understanding of
what these people were doing to filter
out to the rest of the community and
people wanted to kind of jump on it and
pursue it an advantage way
take them well to even find out about it
whereas now everybody is kind of every
night there's a new set of pre prints
coming out and the preprint server and
people logging in and looking at these
and the minute that somebody has some
new thing which is becoming a kind of
fetish thing to work on everybody
throughout the world has it at exactly
the same time when their desktop and can
start thinking about it and working on
it and so it kind of makes that even
more so than it used to be